جفاره نسمع ايضا من مازن ابراهيم روايه
حزب
الله عن مجمل تطورات هذه الجبهه لاسما
عمليه التسلل الى مزارع الشبع التي تحدث
عنها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في الواقع زين العابدين يمكن
القول اننا اليوم ااء عمليتين نوعيتين من
ضمن ست عمليات اعلن عنها حزب الله على
كامل الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان عمليه كوفال
التي بنها حزب الله تحدث عن انه اطلق
الصواريخ باتجاه قوه لجيش الاحتلال في هذه
المستوطنه بخلاف ما يتم ايراده من الجانب
الاسرائيلي عن ان المستهدف هو من
المستوطنين البيان الرسمي لحزب الله يتحدث
عن قوه عسكريه تابعه لجيش الاحتلال
وبطبيعه الحال استهداف الان نسمع دوي غاره
يبدو انها نفذتها الطائرات الاسرائيليه
التي كانت تحلق في سماء المنطقه قصف اضافي
زين العابدين بالنس بالنسبه لحزب الله هو
يستهدف هذه المستوطنات التي تقع عند
الحافه الاماميه مع الحدود اللبنانيه
باعتبار انه تم اخلائها من كافه
المستوطنين من قبل سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الفتره الماضيه وبالتالي
انطلاقا من هذا المعطى هو يتعامل مع هذه
ال مستوطنات بوصفها ثكنات عسكريه من هنا
يفهم الاستهداف المتكرر للمطل لكريات
شمونه لغيرها من المستوطنات بالاضافه الى
كوفال اليوم والتي تحدث عن استهداف لقوه
من جن جيش الاحتلال ولكن الاهم ايضا ما
حدث على مستوى تلالك فرشو ومزارع شبعه حزب
الله لم يتبنى هذه العمليه ولكن ما رصدناه
من خلال اشخاص يتابعون بشكل لصيق العمليات
التي تحصل في تلك المنطقه نتحدث عن اعالي
مرتفعات القطاع الشرقي من جنوب لبنان
والمتاخمة رويسات العلم الاسرائيلي في
تلالك فرشو المحتله اعقب هذا الانفجار
لمده ربع ساعه اطلاق نار متبادل بمعنى ان
الموقع الاسرائيلي كان يطلق من رشاشه
النيران باتجاه محيط هذا الموقع في
المقابل تم سماع اطلاق رصاص متبادل اي ان
هنالك مجموعه في تلك المنطقه تبادلت اطلاق
النار مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتمركزه في موقع رويسات العلم بعد اطلاق
النار لمده ربع ساعه بدات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باطلاق بشكل تدريجي قضائ
المدفعيه في البدايه كانت قضائ المدفعيه
تطلق باتجاه المحيط الملاصق لموقع رويسات
العالم لقوات الاحتلال تطور هذا الامر من
خلال اطلاق عشرات القذائف في محيط بلده
كفرشوبا وايضا وصولا الى الهبريه وبلده
شبعه كل هذا القصف كان دليلا على ان هنالك
محاوله تسلل وهذا ما رصدناه من خلال اطلاق
النار المتبادل ولكن عمليا حتى الان لم
يصدر اي تبني رسمي من طرف معلوم بمعنى حتى
الان من كان ينفذ العمليات في تلك المنطقه
وبعجن القدس كتائب القسام قوات الفجر او
حزب الله لم يعلن تبني هذه العمليه ولكن
صدرت بعض البيانات المجهوله المصدر والتي
تتحدث عن هذه العمليه وعن استشهاد اشخاص
تسللوا من تلك المنطقه